hi everyone this is professor on dust
science
and today i want to discuss central
potentials in another one of our videos
on rigorous quantum mechanics
a central potential is a potential that
only depends on the distance with
respect to the origin
another way of saying this is that if
you are exactly at the center of the
potential
then the potential looks exactly the
same in all directions and you probably
already know some for example the
isotropic
three-dimensional harmonic oscillator or
the spherical box
however the reason that central
potentials are so important is not these
examples that we just mentioned
it's something that at first sight might
seem entirely unrelated
it turns out that when we have two
particles whose
interaction only depends on the distance
between them
then their relative motion can be
described using a single fictitious
particle
that moves in a central potential the
most important system of this type
is the hydrogen atom so i hope i've
convinced you that we really must
study central potentials and today we
will do two things
first i want to define what a central
potential is
and second i want to show that central
potentials are very much related to the
angular momentum
so let's go the most convenient way to
think about a central potential is to
work in terms of spherical coordinates
as a quick refresher let's set up a
coordinate system in three dimensions
let's also consider a vector r
which in spherical coordinates we will
describe with
three numbers the first number is the
length of the vector
r and as a length the coordinate
r can take any value between zero and
infinity
the second number is the angle between
the vector r and the third axis and we
call it the polar angle and label it
with
theta theta runs between zero and pi
and for the third number we first
project the vector
r onto the horizontal plane and then we
measure the angle with respect to the
first axis
calling it the azimuthal angle and label
it with phi
and 5 runs between 0 and 2 pi
now in this language a general potential
is a potential v that depends on the
position vector
r which in spherical coordinates means
that it depends on the three numbers
r fisa and phi and a
central potential is a potential v that
only depends on the distance from the
origin
so it only depends on the scalar r
put another way if we are at the origin
then the potential looks exactly the
same in
all directions it is invariant under any
rotation
about the origin examples of central
potentials include
the isotropic three-dimensional harmonic
oscillator
or the spherical box another key family
of systems that can be described
using a central potential is that of two
quantum particles interacting
via a potential that only depends on the
distance between the two particles
as we discuss in the corresponding video
that is linked in the description
the interesting physics of these two
particle systems only depends
on the relative motion of the two
particles which amounts to describing a
single
fictitious particle moving in the
central potential
and the most famous example of this is
the hydrogen atom
overall all of these problems involve
the motion of particles in three
dimensions
so it is most convenient to work in the
position representation
and this is what we will do next
the general hamiltonian of a one
particle system has a kinetic energy
term
and a potential energy term from the
videos on the position representation
we know that the position operator
acting on the state psi
acts as a multiplicative factor on the
position representation
and that the momentum operator acting on
the state
psi acts as a differential operator
in the position representation using
these results
we can rewrite the hamiltonian with this
kinetic energy term
and this potential energy term
as we've already discussed due to the
spherical symmetry of central potentials
it
is most convenient to work in terms of
spherical coordinates
we already know that by definition of a
central potential
the potential energy term here only
depends on the distance from the origin
when we write it in spherical
coordinates
for the kinetic energy term we
essentially need to write
the laplacian in spherical coordinates
this is what it looks like which is a
well-known result that you can easily
consult in many mathematics resources
including wikipedia the expression for
the laplacian
in spherical coordinates is admittedly
rather long
but from a fundamental point of view you
can obtain it from the more common
expression
in cartesian coordinates simply by
following the standard mathematics of
changes of variables
and i should also add that there are a
few alternative but mathematically
equivalent ways of writing the laplacian
in spherical coordinates and the reason
i'm using this particular one
will become clear in a moment if your
preferred reference gives you an
alternative form
then it should be straightforward to
rewrite it into this form that we will
use today
so with this expression for the
laplacian we can rewrite the hamiltonian
as having this very long kinetic energy
term
which essentially means copying the
expression for the laplacian with an
extra pre-factor
and then the central potential term
okay so we now come to one of the key
insights
about central potentials remember from
the videos on
orbital angular momentum that you can
find linked in the description
that the square orbital angular momentum
operator
can be written in the positioned
representation using spherical
coordinates
like this we'll have a quick
recap about orbital angular momentum in
a moment and
for now you can simply take this as a
given
if we now compare this expression with
this term
here we see that it is simply equal to
minus l squared over h bar squared
this means that we can rewrite the
hamiltonian of a particle moving in a
central potential
as the sum of three terms the fast comes
from the kinetic energy
here and depends on derivatives with
respect to r
the second also comes from the kinetic
energy and it is the term
proportional to the angular momentum
squared here
giving this
and the third is simply our original
central potential
this is a rather nice expression because
we can see that all the angular
dependence of the hamiltonian is
contained in this orbital angular
momentum
operator we have already solved the
problem of orbital angular momentum in
quantum mechanics
for example we've already shown that the
corresponding eigenfunctions
are given in terms of spherical
harmonics
as we will see today this means that
we've actually already solved part of
the problem of a particle moving in a
central potential
and all that we will have to do is
to solve the radial part of the problem
this latest expression that we've
obtained for the hamiltonian of a
particle moving
in a central potential suggests that
there is a close relation between
central potentials and angular momentum
and this is what i want to explore next
to do so
let's first quickly recap what we
learned about orbital angular momentum
in the corresponding videos the angular
momentum operator
l is really made of three operators
lx ly and lz
in the videos on orbit angular momentum
we write
these operators in spherical coordinates
and
we find that they all only depend on the
angular variables for example the lz
operator in spherical coordinates is
simply this
the l squared operator that we
introduced a moment ago which is equal
to
lx squared plus ly squared plus lz
squared also only depends on the angular
variables
also remember that l squared commutes
with all
components of angular momentum
even though the individual angular
momentum components do not commute
amongst themselves
the key observation here is that orbital
angular momentum operators
only depend on the angular variables but
do not depend
on the radial variable r this means that
any angular momentum operator will
commute with any term
that only depends on the variable r
in particular if we look at the
hamiltonian up here
then the first term here and the third
term here
only depend on r this means that any
angular momentum operator
will commute with both of them
on top of this the second term is
proportional to l squared here
and as l squared commutes with itself
then this implies that the full
hamiltonian commutes with l
squared as the various components of l
also commute with l squared as shown
here
then this also means that the full
hamiltonian commutes with
every component of l
we know that any operator that commutes
with a hamiltonian is a constant of
motion in quantum mechanics
so these results here show that the
angular momentum
is a constant of motion for particles
moving
in central potentials
we've just seen that the angular
momentum components and the square
angular momentum are all constants of
motion for particles moving in central
potentials
this means that we have a large number
of operators that we can pick
to develop the quantum theory of central
potentials
however as the orbital angular momentum
operators
don't commute amongst themselves then we
can limit the choice to a subset
of compatible observables
as is conventionally done the compatible
observables that we'll choose are the
hamiltonian h
the square angular momentum squared and
the z component
of angular momentum as these three
operators all commute amongst themselves
we can always choose a common set of
eigenstates
mathematically we can write the
eigenvalue or equation of the
hamiltonian
the eigenvalue equation of l squared
and the eigenvalue equation of lz
these three eigenfunctions here here
and here are the same you can also see
that i've written the eigenvalues of l
squared as l times l plus 1 times h bar
squared
and those of l said as ml times h bar
we obtained these expressions for the
eigenvalues of l squared and l z
in the corresponding videos that you
have in the description as a quick
reminder
l can only take non-negative integer
values
and for a given l ml can only be
one of these values in steps of one
overall this means that the solution of
a particle moving in a central potential
can be rewritten as the solution of this
set of three simultaneous equations
for the commuting observables h l
squared and
l z in the position representation
this means that we end up with three
differential equations
luckily we already have the solution of
these two equations from our study of
angular momentum
so the problem boils down to solving the
top equation
so to understand the quantum mechanics
of systems described by
central potentials we need to
simultaneously solve
these three differential equations
in general these differential equations
depend on three variables because they
describe a particle moving in 3d space
however we already know from the videos
on orbital angular momentum
that the angular momentum eigenfunctions
can be separated into a radial part
and an angular part
this angular part is entirely determined
by the solution
of the angular momentum eigenvalue
equations and
is given by a family of functions called
spherical harmonics
overall this means that the angular
functions are the same
in any central potential whether we have
hydrogen atom
or an isotropic harmonic oscillator or
anything you can think of
the problem boils down to figuring out
what the radial function
are here looks like in the companion
video on the radial equation
we set up the differential equation that
is obeyed by
r and we see that this equation depends
on the form
of the central potential which means
that the radial functions
are different for every central
potential
in turn this means that we have to
calculate the radial function
r separately for each central potential
and you can find a few examples in the
corresponding videos
but today we'll just leave it here
central potentials are intimately
related to angular momentum because
we've already solved the angular
momentum elsewhere
that means that we already know how the
state of a quantum particle in a central
potential
depends on angular variables so all we
have left to do is to determine
the radial dependence of the wave
function so as a next step i would
encourage you to check out the companion
video on the radial equation and after
that you can really explore any central
potential that you want
but of course the one that i recommend
is a hydrogen atom and as always if you
liked this video please subscribe